andreas gassen herzlich willkommen beim
live
drittel ist zu was der
kanzleramtsminister gerade sagt da es
eben aktuell wegen fehlender strategie
wegen fehlender struktur wegen der
abgebauten impfzentren die kassenärzte
überfordert sind die niedergelassenen
ärzte überfordert sind jetzt die große
zahl der nötigen booster impfung zu
wirken
also man muss schon eine gewisse kritik
kann man seitens der ärzteschaft schon
an der stelle abgeben zum einen haben
die kollegen in den krankenhäusern damit
zu tun dass ihnen die intensivstation
verlaufen und sie nicht mehr wissen wie
sie der situation zumindest regional
herr werden und die niedergelassenen
kolleginnen kollegen sollen jetzt
innerhalb kürzester zeit die ausgerufene
booster impfung von 40 millionen stimmen
das sind beides aufgaben die kaum zu
erledigen sind und ist natürlich dann
immer wohlfeil auf die ärzteschaft zu
zeigen dass es da nicht funktioniert
wenn selbst politisch über den sommer
nicht viel passiert weil wahlkampf ist
und plötzlich stellt man überrascht fest
dass winter ist und die zahlen in die
höhe gehen das problem sind aber aus
meiner sicht gar nicht mal unbedingt nur
die booster impfung die sind ja
priorität wichtig für die alten und
wirklich kranken die die gefahr der
schweren impf durchbrüche haben sondern
wir haben einfach immer noch eine eben
flügge die relativ gravierend ist gerade
auch bei den über 60 jährigen mit auf
intensivstationen landen halt im
wesentlichen um geimpfte und eben auch
hoch betagte patientin sofern hat jetzt
sparen rechnen dass auch die booster
impfung die helfen gegen diese aktuelle
situation nicht weil das ist tatsächlich
ein problem der vielen ungelösten
ich höre in diesem moment aus der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vielleicht
lese ich das einfach mal direkt vor was
gerade passiert ist die kanzlerin hat
sich noch einmal geäußert und hat gesagt
wir sind in einer dramatischen notlage
sehen sie das genauso
diese müssten diese rhetorik immer einen
ticken zu viel also es ist jetzt ja
nicht was überraschend kommt deshalb in
die muss ich sagen das ist wird
irgendwann noch ärgerlich und das
problem ist ja auch da sich ja viele in
diesen dramatischen äußeren überschlagen
war es die befolgung mittlerweile gar
nicht sie ist wenn sie das jede woche
hören glauben sie es auch nicht mehr
ohne frage haben wir extrem hohe
infektionszahlen da sind sicherlich auch
viele kinder dabei dass noch viele
infektionen die nicht in krankheiten
gibt aber wir haben natürlich eine
steigende belegung auch der
intensivstation auch wenn sie neulich
das hohe niveau des letzten der letzten
welle erreichte bis zu 5700 patienten
hatten aber natürlich ist die situation
alles andere als gut und jetzt muss man
sich natürlich die frage stellen wir
haben einen instrumentenkasten auch mit
dem neuen infektionsschutzgesetz der
eigentlich ausreichend ist das problem
ist nur wenn ihn niemand anwendet dann
passiert natürlich auch nichts und in
zweijähriger es wunderbar wenn die
niemand kontrolliert nützt hier
natürlich nichts also von daher muss man
eigentlich sich in der politik
vielleicht an der einsatzstelle waren
die eigene nase fassen inwieweit man
maßnahmen auch umgesetzt hat
beispielsweise in bayern oder auch in
sachsen wo jetzt für die proof nach
lockdown laut werden der bundesweit
sicherlich überhaupt keinen sinn macht
welchen maßnahmen brauchen wir denn
konkret lassen sie uns das thema impfen
reden lassen sie uns über die
impfzentren reden die zum großen teil
geschlossen wurden welche maßnahmen
brauchen wir konkret damit wenig alle
dann doch in diesem lockdown dann doch
am ende steuern
also wir müssen auf jeden fall völlig
klar die booster impfung für die alten
übersichtlich oder meint übersichtlich
und die mit mehreren erkrankungen
vorantreiben ich darf an der stelle nur
sagen wir haben für die nächste
bestellung der praxis 5 millionen
impfdosen als bestellung das heißt die
praxen geben massiv gas aber die können
natürlich manche versäumnisse der
letzten wochen und auch nicht in zwei
wochen kompensieren und das zweite ist
wir müssen und da bin ich sehr viel
skeptischer wir müssten eigentlich die
erreichen die bisher nicht geimpft sind
ich bin aber ziemlich sicher dass wir
leider einen hohen anteil bei ungewissen
haben die sich einfach nicht impfen
lassen wollen und das ist ein problem
und deshalb werden wir dieses problem
auch kaum in den griff bekommen und
insofern ist die forderung die viele
jahre formulieren nach zweig sozusagen
dann der blogger führung glich durch die
hintertür wahrscheinlich die krücke die
wir über den winter benutzen werden
müssen um zu versuchen die
infektionszahlen griff zu kriegen wohl
wissend dass ist ein großteil der
infektion eben nicht beim friseur in
restaurants steht sondern im privaten
bereich der kassen jetzt haben wir auch
in dieser sendung schon gehört
einerseits dass die impfpflicht kommen
soll für pfleger in den krankenhäusern
also für die die da im krankenhaus eine
corona front arbeiten das scheint mehr
oder weniger beschlossene sache und
gleichzeitig haben wir hier von
klinikpersonal auf der intensivstation
auch gehört wie hoch die belastung ist
und was man sich dafür sorgen macht für
die nächsten wochen werde es eine idee
dass die niedergelassenen ärzte dass das
personal dort in den praxen aus hilft
denn die praxis meistens über
weihnachten geschlossen also kann man
nicht daran klein tausch machen
also zum einen sind die praxen in der
regel schon weit gehen auch zwischen den
tagen besetzt und man muss einfach sagen
dass personal ob ärzte oder pfleger auf
intensivstationen ist natürlich
besonders geschult ausgebildet hoch
qualifiziert da können sie jetzt nicht
einfach mit personal aus anderen
bereichen kompensieren das ist ja das
problem sonst könnte man das ja auch im
krankenhaus tun also wir haben einfach
ein problem was seit vier jahren besteht
offengestanden zu wenig qualifiziertes
personal
unter zum teil auch nicht von möglichen
arbeitsbedingungen in den krankenhäusern
das recht sich halt in solchen krisen
insofern können wir hier relativ
schwierig personell aushelfen wir müssen
halt schauen dass wir
versuchen die zahlen zu bremsen es wird
dazu kommen das machen ja die ersten
kranken also schon dass man wahl
operationen wieder verschiebt und das
ist natürlich
für die patienten die eine operation
anstehen haben die für sie ja auch
wichtig ist und notwendig ist schon eine
bittere pille und letztlich muss man
sagen das ist im weiten teilen
tatsächlich den zu verdanken die sich
nicht impfen lassen denn die stellen den
löwen anteil derjenigen die auf
intensivstationen werden sagt dr andreas
gassen herzlichen danke ihnen für das
gespräch